well I'll exclude the last preposition
and say that it is a typical problem in
a large corporation that most employees
will not be able to absorb the the
attitudes and the principles the people
at the top sometimes that's good
sometimes that's bad a lot of that is
path dependent if it depends upon how
dominant the founder is or how dominant
the current executive is and how
involved he or she is with the employees
but certainly there for large companies
and mine was a small company we never
when I left we only had 75 people for
large companies being able to have the
sorts of meetings that we that we had
would be increasingly difficult however
there are companies that do attempt to
do that where they do have
teleconferences where they get on
hundreds of employees in a position
where they can participate as the CEO
questions I'm not I don't know whether
or not the CEO is giving them full fair
and accurate disclosure of what's going
on I know we did but I do know that
people try to offset those but a lot of
times they they are unable to offset the
gradual dissolution of a company culture
which often occurs over time of them
with expansion